so i feel bad you know because i i
empathize with somebody who
is scared to come forward won't be
honest about it
but i also feel like at a certain point
if you
know what you're doing is destroying
something someone
society and you're like well i'm not
going to stick my neck out
i mean that's kind of messed up yeah and
there's no other option it's a
choiceless choice to do this work
because people are not going to speak on
the record nobody will ever do that
i mean some people well some once in a
while i mean you had the eric cochran
our colleague at pinterest was making a
ton of money
and he gave it all up and he said i just
i don't what am i going to do but he
ashes to ashes one day and go to the
grave and i'm young i
want to do this i hope to find more of
these people we have a tip line
veritas that's v-e-r-i-t-a-s tips at
protonmail.com for those of you watching
if you want to be brave and do something
yeah
so there's a lot of options you know man
i
i worked so you know this i worked for a
disney company
it was dis it was abc univision and it's
interesting
you you said something that reminded me
of what they told me
side with the audience yeah the goal of
this news outlet fusion
as i was told multiple times by the
president was to just
say things that the audience would agree
with and so i asked him
if there is a story that's factually
true but would upset our audience
we wouldn't report it and he said i
think that's fair how does that
translate
let's say you have raw footage of a
proud boy walking down the street
and then antifa runs up to him and
punches him in the face the proud boy
gets up and punches back
the full context would offend our
audience we don't report it
the shorter context would not offend our
audience the proud boy hitting antifa
that's the story that complements their
world view the proud boys are bad
so ultimately i didn't i never blew the
whistle or anything
while i was there but i refused to play
ball with them i ended up leaving
and then basically explaining everything
about what you know what these companies
do how they do it
how the media manipulates and
i think too many people have said to me
things like
oh well this is really funny to me they
say yeah but you could support yourself
but
you know you weren't worried about what
you know what you were like you were
going to lose your job
you didn't care like i cared about all
that stuff i was worried that coming out
i did a video that uh sargon of akkad
put on his channel
where it was me breaking down four
different ways i think it was four that
the media was manipulating everybody
and i knew i'm like i'm gonna put out a
video on this you know this youtuber
you know anti-feminist guy's channel
they're not gonna hire me this is it
i'm gonna say this right now let
everybody know and this is how we're
going to get it out because these
companies won't let me say it
and then i better start something on my
own because i'm never going back to
these companies i had actually gone to a
bunch of these i'm not going to name
them but
you know who they are these big new york
digital firms and and some of them were
like you name your job you name your
salary and i said
i am not going to get i saw some people
working there i'm not going to get
myself in a situation like that anymore
and so i decided just build it up from
the ground you're an entrepreneur and
that's very important what you're doing
it's it's like you have to be a
journalist and a businessman
at the same time i mean it's very
important you are an entrepreneur i'm at
your place right now and
it's amazing what you are building and
what you've built and
and and and what i've learned in my
career is that when i started i was in a
garage with
nothing but a mic and a laptop and i
realized okay in order to make videos i
have to do something else and do and
have to be the chairman of a company and
i don't settle litigation to raise
millions of dollars so in order to do
what i think is right in order to not
compromise or ever sell out i haven't
sold out to anyone i'm not answering to
anybody i have no advertisers
no one can boycott me i had to build
a company and learn how to be a ceo
in order to do my passion which is
investigative reporting otherwise i
can't do investigative reporting because
i have to be owned by somebody right and
that's what you're doing
and more power to you well so the reason
the reason i tell the story is just
because my own personal experience with
not i'm not going to pretend it's as
brave as some of the whistleblowers
you've seen
because my contract expired i was i was
i was on i was in golden handcuffs i
couldn't do anything they wouldn't
they i i was straight up told by the
president i wasn't allowed to
participate in a presidential event
because of my race because i looked too
white wow
i was told that and i was actually
contemplating like do i sue them for
this and i was like i don't wanna i
don't wanna get involved in any of that
i just wanna i wanna carry on
but what i'm trying to get to is when
you say be
brave that's exactly it a lot of people
seem to think that they're
like they look to me they look to
successful people and say you're the
exception
i know that if i strike out on my own
that i'm going to fail
no no you have to just try you've got it
you've got to throw it out there
so if you're i'll tell you this man you
have two choices if you work for one of
these companies
and you know they're doing something
wrong and you say well i'm not getting
my hands dirty or taking my neck out
then then how are you not a part of the
problem
you are if you see something and you
decide i am going to stand up and let
people know what they're doing you are
solving that problem
yes but there are too many people who
are more than happy to just let the
problem carry on
well you know that's that's true and uh
i think uh you got to be a leader in
this life you got
you got to take risks courage is the
virtue that sustains all others
um i don't think it you need to have a
hundred thousand people or a million you
just need a few you need like a couple
dozen
again going back to this example of eric
cochran you meet this guy he works with
us he runs our
this is the pinterest pinterest
whistleblower and it was just you know
brings tears to your eyes to hear him
talk about
he left a salary very high salary and he
describes why he did it and he says a
lot of people go through life
and they just want the material things
in life and that's not what life is
about and
you get a lot more fulfillment in
standing up for something that is right
and i don't think i could ever do
anything but project veritas i've tried
to live a normal life i've tried to go
to law school and do all these things
and
i i just feel so passionately that if
you stand up for what's right and moral
and decent
like you have done in your career um you
know good things will happen
and i don't know what the alternative is
do you know the story of how the nobel
peace prize or the nobel prize came
about no
it's uh the dude nobel inventor of
dynamite
someone a news outlet i guess
accidentally published his obituary
early
and i'm probably flubbing some of the
details because i'm not pulling it off
the website or anything
but apparently they accidentally
published his obituary early it happens
and they called him the merchant of
death and so he apparently got panicked
it was like is that my legacy so he
decided to create something to be
you know to be better the nobel prize
and all the chemistry engineering
mathematics peace prize et cetera
i think people it's it's maybe maybe
it's something that not all people
have this feeling about what you're
going to leave behind
but i'm curious if you know these people
at google who refuse to speak up
the people who are there like look
clearly not everybody at google is a
zealot
who wants to manipulate people and
control the world thinking their
ideology is legit this guy clearly
doesn't he thinks they're playing god
and something wrong with what they're
doing it's unethical
but why wouldn't he just actually come
out
and and give that statement put out that
video and say hey guys this is happening
why like what do people not care about
the legacy that
they leave behind i think people i think
people are afraid
i think that you know the only thing you
have to fear is fear can
fear itself but the biggest question
that i get asked uh is what can i do do
you get asked that question
all the time it's like what can i do
what can i do and you know dennis prager
says there's three types of people in
the world there's people who
fight people who support those who fight
maybe financially and those who do
nothing
so you know you could certainly
financially support those who who do
things
or you can do things or you can do
nothing it's those it's those are the
three options
the biggest question i get asked is how
can i help how can i contribute
and and i'm not saying it's for
everybody but there's a tiny fraction
of people who i mean this guy zach
voorhees another one i didn't mention at
google algorithmic unfairness
zach leaked the document out of google
and he was terminated by google
and he said quote this was an act of
atonement
an attempt to make my conscience clear
very powerful
and he meant it it was tearing up and um
you know it's just some people can it's
a choiceless
choice they can't they can't do anything
and whistleblowing which is what
sort of what some of us do at project
veritas because a lot of people are not
my employees they're
actually people who just send me stuff
it's like you're an astronaut which is
let go from the spacecraft you're not
part of any organization you're not part
of veritas you're not part of google
you're just out there floating out out
in the wind
with no safety net for a higher purpose
and in the in the 20th century you had
jeffrey weigan and these sorts of
whistleblowers who were their lives were
over all they had was 60 minutes
yeah but in this day and age there's
gofundme
there's a life after whistleblowing but
although that's right the go fund me
but there's there's there's a new market
for this sort of thing there's a
it used to be in the 20th century you'd
get divorced you'd be bankrupt your life
would be over
most whistleblowers have reportedly said
that they regretted doing it
wow they they wish they could do they
were naive i think there's a new
era i think there's a new age i think
we're living in an era of
these are the times that try men's souls
to quote thomas paine i think
it there's like this new movement of
people that are about to do this tim
yeah because you were talking last night
or we're gonna go to war okay well
before we go to war there's gonna be
whistleblowers recording everything
i think to quote breitbart yeah yes
breitbart exactly so you know yeah so
last night we were we were talking about
where where do we go from here like
what's and you were saying i think civil
unrest and i said yeah i do believe that
the trajectory we're on leads to
full-scale conflict of some kind
what that looks like i don't know and i
know it's it's interesting
you know a lot of people don't like the
conversation around potential civil or
anything like that but i'm
i i think people get confused about what
it really means i'm not talking about
factions marching in the streets anytime
soon or anything like that
but i do think that we're seeing this
and i i'm gonna i'm gonna pause right
here and i've been i wanted to say this
as soon as we pull up this article
i got i got bad news for you man
this doesn't shock anybody anymore you
know it's like i i think it's really
really important you're putting the
stuff out you're showing it you're
confirming it you're proving it
right and it's at a point now where like
i see this and i'm like
i know i know yeah so what do we do
it's like we're hitting a wall you know
what i mean well i don't i don't know if
i agree
completely i think that you need a you
need to do more of it
this is like i do these things i used to
do these things once a month and i'm
doing them like three times a week and
it was uh you know right andrew
breitbart whatever called righteous
indignation which i believe was coined
by ida tarball the investigative
reporter
investigative reporting and there's
another book called custodians of
conscience so we test investigative
reporting
tests and affirms what is moral and what
is not moral and that there's that
overton window where you're kind of
testing where the boundaries are about
and you're saying
the threshold of anger it's hard because
there's so much noise and crap
how do you break through that
investigative reporting is the
fiercest fiercest of indignation fused
with the hardest of fact
so you're trying to find these facts
that are outrageous to people
um and it is hard but
i think it's working eric eric sprachman
i think we're i think we're getting
there
i think we just have to do more of it i
think we need
you know you need 100 videos and the
audience is not going to watch cnn
because they can't stand it i mean cnn
has no viewers by the way nobody watches
cnn
actually actually their viewers have
been going up oh yeah yeah it's a weird
phenomenon right now tucker carlson of
course as you probably as you've
probably heard has the highest rated
cable news show in history
over five million in you know the pa
like a week or two ago massive
but uh around the same time rachel
maddow and anderson cooper have been
skyrocketing as well
so it's what numbers are we talking
about i'm talking about anderson cooper
hitting three million
three million three million and rachel
maddow hitting four within one night we
can we can we can
average average over the week we can
beat that well i'll tell you this
uh across my channels i'm getting over
100 there you go and on youtube cnn's
getting 190
so for one person you know it's not bad
and then
this show actually has a couple people
but uh compared to cnn's
you know yeah i think i think they're on
the way up i think they're doing really
well now because of the orange man
narrative
the trump bump you know and tucker's
kind he sort of cuts through a lot of
the bs
so you you know naturally his show does
well but none of these companies none of
these media or
organizations are willing to be the tip
of the spear they're not supposed to go
they don't go there like vice's unique
value proposition was we go there
imagine how broken the media is right
imagine how broken the news business is
when your unique value proposition to
your customers is we go to the place
we're reporting on
people none of these people will ever
have me on tv obviously but they'll talk
about this stuff
and i think it's that idea of of of the
tip of the spear being in an
exposed position where you're not where
you're not just responding to events but
you're actually
creating events the google thing tonight
is new information into the matrix it's
like not just
us talking about pre-existing
information and most media corporations
because they're commercial
that economic that that that that
economic imperative
compromises their their their
what they do i don't have an economic
imperative we have never generated a
penny of profit which
is a pain in the ass because i have to
go work 100 hours a week raising money
to pay bills
but we you know what i'm saying i think
it's economics not ideology
isn't there a partisan element to it
there is there exists it but jeff
zucker i mean everything i've learned
about the guy i mean he could have built
trump up and then he's trying to tear
him down and i don't know what these
companies are going to do after trump
when so so you you do fundraising
relentlessly
real constantly would you consider your
donors to be conservative
some many of them see some of them there
seems to be
a overlap between conservatism
i don't even know what that i don't even
know what that means anymore to be
honest i agree
and reality there seems to be a because
that's the inverse colbert because see
cnn they just keep
yammering about crap i mean i've been
through the ringer with this new york
times and us
they literally say the opposite we
should talk about this the opposite of
what is real
so if so if you if you just you know
extrapolate that over everything they
say
if i just aim my camera in any direction
any direction
it's going to show things that are
contrary to what they show you
is that conservative i don't really
consider myself an ideologue
i really don't i tend to focus on the
sacred cows
the organizations that these places
won't go won't talk about
because i believe in justice i always
have since i was a college student my
professors were telling me how great
stalin was and i said no that's not true
so i guess i'm more of a contrarian if
the media was was was
saying doing the inverse i'd probably my
cameras would show something different
i think how about anti-establishment in
a sense
perhaps so i consider myself to be
fairly anti-establishment and that's why
i'm often ranking on i find myself
ragging on democrats
because i i don't like the republicans
either but
right now with with trump you have
something very different
and so when it comes to the things that
we see on cnn
and msnbc on on mainstream news outlets
these are supposed to be the news
outlets that are informing everybody and
being fair and they're not
they're clearly pandering to one side
and catering to
one political faction in this country so
i i view that as
do i care what breitbart is doing why
why would i care breitbart's not that
big
do i care about what the new york times
is doing absolutely they're the gray
lady the paper of record
when they're when they're acting you
know a fool i'm
worried about that look i get it there's
always going to be some little blog
some right-wing channels or right-wing
news outlet or something and then i hear
all of these you know
you see like brian stelter on cnn saying
fox news does this and i'm like yes so
what it's one channel
they do this sometimes they do that
sometimes what about you guys what about
abc
nbc cbs all of these washington post
they're all endorsing biden they're all
you know not every single one of them a
lot of papers are endorsing a political
candidate
they're putting out information they're
clearly lying about it like
like the twitter fact check did you see
this when the new york post story got
censored
the washington post fact check put up on
twitter said joe biden played no role
in ousting the ukrainian prosecutor even
though he's on video
saying he did this is what they're going
to start doing now is just saying the
quite literal
opposite of reality this happened it
would happen to us i'm aware of it
yeah well so so anyway my point is i i
i view things as like the establishment
is breaking the rules and that's a
problem to me
if there are people who oppose the
establishment who are much smaller who
are breaking the rules i'll bring it up
when it matters but i don't think it's
that significant
like i understand it can be in concert
with all these other channels but anyway
that's
that's just me kind of breaking down my
point of view uh as it relates to you
you guys have been accused of being you
know partisan conservative
and going after left-wing organizations
and and trying to smear them or whatever
so well well i mean i mean there's
there's a lot of examples to the
contrary i mean
we went after the republican attorney
general of new hampshire recently
because he
his deputy said that there was no such
thing as voter id in the state and i
confronted gordon macdonald who is a
republican who works for chris sununu
who is a republican
there are examples in amy robach the
jeffrey epstein video that wasn't
conservative or liberal that was
actually
plotted by liberals and suddenly the new
republic was like is james o'keefe
legitimate now
i actually have a headline that said
that it's like the moment i go after
like
the nra we live in a world not of angels
but angles where people don't
talk about they don't they don't ever
think that our motives are appear there
must be a polit and not everything's
political
i i would what's going to happen to him
eventually is that whistleblowers are
just going to trust me because they
don't settle lawsuits and don't back
down
and there's going to be 10 20 30 40 of
our sources that just bring us
straight up corruption if someone comes
to me republicans ripping up ballots i
will air
that video i guaran i swear to god if
someone gives me a video
of republican congressmen do it i'm
publishing the video
but i don't get videos of republicans
i get a guy in minnesota who says
absentee ballot it we don't care that
it's illegal
right it's the guy is saying i don't
care that it's illegal and the new york
times says there's no evidence this is
unsubstantiated
well what would it take to what is
substance what is
evidence the guy's on tape he's covered
in it's like a southpaw
it's like parker and stone come up with
the most outrageous video they're
writing 22. let's get
let's get some somalis let's put them in
a car let's say i'm still hustling at
two in the morning ripping up absentee
ballots blank ballots i break the law
it looks like a south park episode and
the new york times goes
this is unsubstantiated so it's it's his
own video
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy because
if you have the incontrovertible
evidence and they and the new york times
says it's unsubstantiated and and and
the information monopolists at facebook
only cite quote unquote verified you you
guys all know this and jeff bezos we're
speaking the washington post i have a
quote here
this is jeff bezos maybe the most
biggest most powerful company amazon in
the world
quote even though the washington post is
a complexifier for me i do not at all
regret my investment
the post is a critical institution with
a critical mission
this is quote something i will be most
proud of
i think it's very telling the ceo of
amazon thinks that his investment in
some
woke click bait rag in washington is the
most
is the most important thing he will have
done in his life wow
the media that is more powerful than all
three branches of the government
of the united states yep and that's so
true so anyway what i was getting to
in terms of the bias accusations against
you what i really love about this was
when you're
you're publishing google yes is google a
left-wing institution no when they say
that you're you're targeting liberal
organizations or elections
they're almost admitting yeah that's
true that these big tech companies
are they are the newspapers are the
democrat media complex i think ritesh le
carre tonight we're gonna have more
videos tomorrow and he does say that
they're that they are they lean that way
and it appears to be tim
the case that they are partisan
institutions and some of the evidence in
these tapes you'll see one tomorrow
which it might even trigger an fec
complaint there is a hearing next week
in dc the senate committee what is it
eric the uh
senate commerce committee is having a
hearing and i'm sure they'll play some
of this
if they're helping left-wing parties
democrat parties in advertising on
google that triggered fec violation
i think uh speaking of the washington
post and how social media amplifies
you know a lot of what these journalists
do verifying them giving them
credibility i love it when i see a
verified journalist with 300 followers
well they're verified they work for the
news outlet that's why it's important i
guess and uh
let me tell you a story and i think it i
think it may have been 2016. it's been a
while now
the washington post published a story
that insinuated
out of thin air that kim.com the
notorious mega upload hacker
fabricated a trove of emails or
something
to i got a pair it's been a long time
since i've covered the story but
they basically wrote this story claiming
that he may have hacked seth rich's
email account or tried to break into
seth rich's email account
to plant a trove of fake emails to prove
quote unquote proof
the seth rich conspiracy theory that d
was it the dnc staffer seth richard
leaked emails uh
that that's the conspiracy i guess to
wikileaks they made this whole story up
completely fabricated so the the general
story was that
uh someone in the rich family got a mega
upload email saying they signed up
and from that tidbit this guy dave
weigel at the washington post
fabricated this whole thing so i went on
twitter i found his his number and i
called him and i was like
you know i said i sent him i said i
think i sent him a signal message like
where to what's you know can you
i was very polite very very professional
saying hi my name is tim i'm a
journalist
i'm curious as to your sources to verify
blah blah blah and
he just was like oh what is this what is
this basically the sum of the story
a fake story was written to smear
kim.com
and uh people who were concerned about
wikileaks release
with no evidence and then i think it was
maybe six or eight months later
they went back and changed the entire
story and you can track all of this
on newsdiffs.org which i'm not sure if
they exist anymore but at the time
they showed you the difference from the
original article and the article as it
was changed in november i think it was
it was published in may i think
it was a smear a hit job and then after
the dust settles
in november they go in and they change
all the language without telling anybody
i've seen this so many times and they
so when you have the washington post
friends that doesn't like that and i've
seen it
they endorse joe biden and then they put
up this
this false twitter fact check i love it
twitter had this fake fact check up
for for days were you able to pull it up
or did you i'm trying to right now but
uh uh but i just want to say while
you're talking to me about this the
people on your show that people watching
this are there are insiders
that are reaching out to our encrypted
proton mail address right already like
right now
my chief operation just sent me a
message james there's people
literally right now insiders are coming
to the email address
they're watching your show they're
veritas i'm gonna do another ad
veritas tips at protonmail.com you know
that show cars for kids do you ever hear
them yes
yeah one eight seven seven cars for kids
yep veritas tips at protonmail so
james we need my pillow jingle right now
there eric there are insiders coming to
us watching tim fool's show
cool i feel like these tech companies i
feel like we're doing one of those what
are those things they used to do where
they would like raise money on on public
access tv
the phones are ringing telephones
yeah proton mail is being inundated with
whistleblowers as we speak like the live
aid concert
there are people working for tech
companies watching tim pool's
live cast right now oh no who are
emailing project veritas right now
on the inside yeah give me one of those
cameras so we're we're going to get
banned
you are changing the world and you don't
even know it i mean i i i mean i i think
so
you know that's the it's the goal every
day to just do something yes
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you